joining us on the line is dr. Marty
Meharry he's a health policy adviser to
presidents Trump and Obama
editor-in-chief of MedPage Today surgeon
and professor of public health policy at
Johns Hopkins
dr. Meharry thanks so much for joining
show again really appreciate good to be
with your pen so as you watch the
trajectory of the the testing in the
United States a lot more tests being
given a lot more positive test coming up
obviously and a lot of deaths we've now
surpassed 800 deaths in the United
States from coronavirus do you have any
sort of beat at all it's very difficult
to get any sort of real estimate as to
where this thing is going whether we
look like Italy in a week or so
particularly in New York City what's
your take on where this thing goes
in the near term well first of all
thanks for having me on Ben and keep up
the great work with your show this virus
is following the PlayBook this is
playing out exactly as we had predicted
in all the models and projections and we
are probably still about three or four
weeks away from its peak and are the big
concern right now is that during that
peak we are in a position to ration care
because we just don't have enough
ventilators and our response has been a
little slow now when you cite the number
of deaths and you did it just as our
Johns Hopkins map which has been very
popular has done remember you could
probably multiply the number of deaths
by two or three and we can probably
multiply the number of cases by 10 or 20
because as you know there's not been a
lot of testing out there and hospitals
are telling us they have a lot of what
they call influenza like illness --is
that are in the critical care unit but
they've just not been tested and to be
honest with you that's not the been the
priority to test them they're busy
taking care of people and the test
often doesn't change the management
unless you start talking about some of
these newer medications doctormick Harry
I suggested this morning that there were
basically two things that they can be
true ones one is that the death rates
that we're seeing are actually really
inflated the number of people who
actually have then the coronavirus don't
know it haven't been tested for it is
significantly higher as you just
mentioned then the number of people who
have been tested for it and found
positive and also that even if the
deaths are more numerous than than we
are
know that the numerator over the
denominator is gonna be a lot lower
number than even 1.3 percent or
certainly the 8 or 9 percent we're
seeing in in Italy at the same time
because this thing is so transmissible
the sheer overwhelming absolute number
of people who end up in an ICU could
overwhelm the system anyway so the good
news is that if you have corona virus
you may be less likely to die than 1.3
percent the bad news is that a lot more
of us are gonna get corona virus and so
a lot more people are gonna die
that's exactly right and you know I
personally think that case fatality rate
that is the percent of people who die
who actually have the infection is below
1% not far below it's probably in my
personal opinion around 8/10 of 1% if we
look at the Diamond Princess cruise ship
it was kind of a laboratory 705 people
got it 7 died from it and those were
confirmed cases and confirmed deaths we
know that it's hard for this virus to
hurt a young healthy person that is
somebody in their 20s and 30s or younger
we know really no child has died from
this except for a 14 year old and a 16
year old so when you talk about kids
under 12 they can be transmitters but
they're relatively resilient and I think
you're exactly right look we learned a
lot from a memo internally at New York
Presbyterian Hospital where the chief of
surgery and this memo has been on the
internet I tweeted it earlier this week
that he said we've got 300 Kovan 19
cases at New York Presbyterian by the
way that's about a third of the capacity
a big Hospital like that like mine has
about a thousand best but only a hundred
have tested positive because they just
haven't tested the other 200 they
haven't had you know had tests available
so that tells us a lot now in that memo
he said we will probably need about a
thousand ICU beds at Columbia
Presbyterian Hospital within the next
twenty to thirty three days that tells
you the mass need to flatten the curve
reduce community transmission keep
people hunker down and reduce that peak
when it does happen because that will be
a mass rush and a mass influx that could
and right now will result in a rationing
of ventilators
something we don't want to see is
something we're trying to prepare for by
making one ventilator work for three or
four people well speaking about the
ventilator situation yeah for folks who
don't know what a ventilator is first of
all why don't you explain what
ventilator is because we sort of here
and we think it's an air conditioner or
something so exactly it's a ventilator
how vital are they and how many of them
are we actually going to need if the
estimates are correct versus how many
are in circulation right now so when the
lungs get inflamed when there's a lot of
fluid in the lungs when your body
responds to the infection in the lungs
by sending inflammatory mediators
including white blood cell cells the
lung tissue gets inflamed and it can't
exchange oxygen well so you you have
trouble taking a deep breath in you have
trouble getting enough oxygen the
ventilator blows air in and forces it in
and it's what we call mechanical
respiratory support and so and
particularly people who have lung
disease or a later stage in life need
that now we know that about one one
person for every two people we put on
the ventilator will come off the
ventilator is a crutch and it helps them
breathe for the days or a few weeks they
need to get the strength to get that
infection cleared to get the
inflammation down and so we can save
about half of people that we can give a
ventilator to in those late stages of
this illness so what we need to do is
figure out how are we gonna get these
ventilators to the people who need it
right now our country has about a
hundred and thirty thousand ventilators
broad estimate by the way isn't it kind
of embarrassing that nobody knows how
many ventilators we have I mean you
literally see our top health officials
and it's not their fault right these
ventilators might be in in the basement
of a hospital they're ten years old no
one knows if they work you know and so
no one's done the tally but we know that
our country has about a hundred thousand
ICU beds if we take the low end of the
estimate of this infection say 20
percent of our three hundred and fifty
million Americans get this and 15
percent of them need a ventilator or
need a hospitalization
and a quarter of them need a ventilator
you're talking hundreds of thousands of
ventilators in in one of the models that
I have 700,000 Americans could need a
ventilator we've only got a hundred to
130,000 so we need this is going to be
tough times um so for a second you know
let's talk about sort of broader
questions that I think people are asking
right now the we sort of assume a level
of competence or understanding of the
healthcare system many people don't have
so when we say that somebody's been
transferred to the ICU what percentage
of people who are transferred to the ICU
are going to die in the ICU and how what
percentage of people are gonna come out
because I think there's a widespread
perception that if you end up in the ICU
you're dead yeah ICU does not have a
good reputation out there in the world
but in ICU is really an incredible tour
de force of American health care and our
technology and best practices the
reality is the virus runs its course and
there's little we can do except support
your body keep you nourished and keep
you strong provide you the fluids you
need to let you recover on your own and
we know about one and two people who get
the ventilator survive it the other one
out of two people never comes off the
ventilator unfortunately so right now we
need to think about what percent of
people will need a ventilator and how
can we predict using models right the
right number and it's about we think
about a quarter of the hospitalized
patients needed now we're now you'll
hear statistics that you know less than
1% of the deaths are in people under age
50 and the reason is they're the ones
who are getting the ventilators they're
the ones who are getting the support and
the countries where they've rationed it
goes to the younger people I don't like
those questions and I hope we're never
posed with that but right now we're
projected to be in that dilemma so
doctor Meharry when somebody's in
critical condition does that mean that
they're necessarily in the the ICU
because like how does how do these
conditions work you've seen people
listed as serious or critical what what
do all of those sort of categorizations
mean so both critical guarded and
unstable referred to being in an ICU
with
stop monitoring and being often on a
ventilator and that means that there's a
decent chance say 50% or more that we're
concerned you might not survive the ICU
stay the other terms are usually what we
call transition terms but those are the
ones that refer to an ICU level care and
typically we just refer to that as
critical care we're speaking dr. Marty
Meharry health policy advisor to
presidents Trump and Obama and
editor-in-chief of MedPage Today so dr.
Meharry some of the things that people
been talking about are also treatments
that are being made available there's
been talk about for example using blood
plasma of people who may have recovered
from coronavirus the FDA is now proving
that in in sort of crisis cases they've
talked about the use of clinical trials
in order to see if this stuff is
effective the problem of the clinical
trial presumably is that you have to
have a control group and who the hell
wants to volunteer for the control group
in a clinical trial when you got
coronavirus so some of the solutions had
been talked about our blood plasma
obviously the president has really
talked up hydroxychloroquine what what
do you make of some of these of some of
the supposed treatments that are that
are being made available what what are
the data on these things well there's
some early data that sounds promising
and to be honest with you some of the
most exciting things are not even the
things that have been out there in the
media I mean I know of a scientist who
has a medication that reduces that
body's inflammatory response that
damages the lung and that can help get
people through this virus and I believe
it will rescue people but he's not
getting a call back from the FDA and
what is so frustrating is to see these
old guard physicians the medical
establishment which by the way I love
them and they've got great qualities and
my dad is one of them but they have this
mentality that unless you have a
randomized controlled trial
it's basically snake oil and that is
that that is the thinking and look we
love randomized control trials but they
take time they're very involved and we
can learn from patients we can learn
from individuals we can learn from a
series of individuals we can learn from
before-and-after observations we can
learn from
inferences I mean do we need a
randomized control trial to prove that a
parachute works if somebody jumps out of
a plane now we use scientific reasoning
so dr. Meharry well I want to ask you
also about these sort of timeline here
so you've mentioned and maybe three or
four weeks until we hit the peak of this
thing that does raise questions about
whether it's gonna get wiped out by but
they're basically from what I've heard
several sort of paths to this thing
mitigating to the point where people can
go back to life one is the long term
vaccinations obviously people are gonna
have to go back to work before a year or
18 months or the entire world economy
will just shudder and die there's also
the possibility that the summer helps
mitigate some of this there is the
possibility that over time because we've
so failed to contain this thing that
some sort of herd immunity is is built
up and then there's these sort of okay
well we've done the best we can we've
gotten some resources in place and now
we have to start transitioning people
back to work presumably that's what the
Trump administration and president run
particularly is talking about when he
says he'd like to get people back to
work and was hoping for Easter that
seems very early considering that we are
already at the end of March and we're
certainly not gonna hit the peak until
by your estimates at least mid April and
maybe early May what what do you make of
the timeline here and what does the
transition look like well the good news
is I think we're gonna be good by June
or sometime this summer now I know it's
easy to say that but I do think Easter
is optimistic look I love the president
I worked closely with him on the price
transparency work which by the way is
also a part of this new bill that's in
front of Congress right now so good
stuff is happening but look the
president's job is to keep people upbeat
and optimistic and I think it is
unlikely that we're going to be back to
work full steam ahead by Easter but I've
been a big supporter of saying look the
young healthy people with no risk
factors let them work and let them do
essential services right now we need to
keep them back because they are
community transmitters and we don't want
that mass influx of rush of patients
during the peak to result in rationing
so we want to minimize community
transmission but once we hit the peak
that may be a reasonable time to have
our young healthy workforce out there in
the financial services and supply chain
and utilities
and pharmacy and grocery and healthcare
we've got to keep certain services going
just to survive as a country
well dr. Martin make hair really
appreciate time and really appreciate
your insight health policy advisor to
presidents Trump and Obama
editor-in-chief of MedPage Today and
author of The New York Times bestseller
unaccountable go check out all of his
work dr. Mike Harry really appreciate
your time your insight sir thanks for
having me on Ben
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content